welcome back president biden released
his fiscal year
2022 budget last friday night right
before the long memorial day weekend
of course that raised our eyebrows in
all 72 pages
not once does this budget mention border
security
nancy pelosi has said that a budget
should be a statement of our national
values
so let's get into biden's values and
priorities as per
his budget joining me right now is the
ranking member of the house budget
committee missouri congressman jason
smith congressman it's always a pleasure
thank you very much for being here we
have new numbers to share with our
audience this morning we spoke with
brandon judd he is the
head of the border patrol union and he
told us what the apprehensions look like
in terms of illegals coming into texas
we are talking about a continuation
of incredible numbers 172 000
apprehensions in the month of may
48 000 people got away we have no idea
where they went
and there was no mention of any of this
in the budget can you talk to us about
the priorities of the biden
administration
as per his budget maria it's great to be
with you those numbers that you just
shared
are just astounding astounding think
about this
more people have illegally crossed the
southern border
than the entire population of kansas
city missouri now
since january 20th and this budget that
president
biden released a week ago friday in the
afternoon before memorial day holiday
weekend
hoping i guess that the american public
won't see the details within it
it provides 69 trillion dollars of
spending
over 10 years six trillion dollars of
spending just this year
but they couldn't find one additional
dollar
for the border wall let alone a zero
percent increase for homeland when we're
facing this border crisis
it's crazy yeah i mean i want to talk
about the
the uh priorities here because i know
that in the budget
congressman he's got four billion
dollars allocated to central american
countries
so there's zero increase in spending for
homeland security
there's now no increase in defense
spending because when you actually
increase when you actually compare it to
inflation 1.6
increase means it's negative defense
spending uh and yet four billion for
central american countries so are these
the priorities that we're looking at
right now epa gets an increase of 22
percent in the budget
irs getting 80 billion dollars to hire
86 000 new auditors
look at this this is the first budget
that has been released by
the democrats since they have been in
power in over 800 days
since nancy pelosi became speaker of the
house
and as nancy pelosi said a budget is a
statement of their values and
clearly by this budget it shows that
they have very little concern
for our men and women in unifor uniform
in fact
they propose in this budget to spend
more money
in 10 years on interest on our debt
which is 914 billion dollars and they
want to
spend on our military in fact the
increase on military is 1.6
maria which is less than inflation
and like we we mentioned protecting our
homeland a zero percent increase but
they want to increase the epa
by 22 and they want to hire
87 000 new auditors with the irs to go
after men and women
and to make sure that they're paying
their fair share to the irs hold on
crazy wow hold on congressman we got to
get more into this we're going to take a
short break and then i want to ask you
how he's proposing
we pay for all of this six trillion
dollars we'll be right back with more
on biden's budget welcome back and i am
back with congressman
jason smith he is the ranking member on
the house budget committee
and we are walking through president
biden's budget so congressman you were
saying a moment ago
that the president wants to allocate 80
billion dollars to the irs
it feels a little like a deja vu under
the obama administration we had the ira
irs politicized targeting groups that
they didn't agree with
tell me what this 80 billion dollars is
for
you know they're proposing maria to
spend 80 billion dollars to hire
87 000 irs
auditors that's like filling the
national stadium two different times
just to go after families and small
businesses and farmers
to make sure that they're paying their
fair share with the auditors
and they believe that by hiring these 87
000 auditors they're going to be able to
come up with over 700 billion dollars in
revenues
so that means they're going to be
looking under every uh
crook and cranny to find what they can
with
every american which is pretty scary
well you know it it really strikes me
that we are in dangerous times
today is d-day 77 years after
d-day and today we are confronting
first of all thank you to all of our
troops and our courageous men and women
who gave their lives and fought for the
freedom and liberty of this country
today we face even bigger threats with
communist china
and iran as the threats are rising
there's no increase in homeland security
there's no increase in defense spending
let's put up a bar
chart that we have here from your
committee the budget committee
to show us where the spending is going
walk us through this how come there's so
much money going to education
and no money going to homeland security
first off when you look at that bar
chart maria
this is additional increases anything
that
is non-defense roughly has an average of
16 percent or more of an
increase whenever remember we've already
funded all of these agencies where they
have tens of billions of dollars
in leftover funds from the five to six
different
covid packages that have been passed
over the year so they already have more
money than what they possibly can spend
and that they're not spending but when
it comes to securing our border
you see not one dollar in additional
spending
and when it comes to providing for our
men and women in uniform
it's the spit the increase is so minimal
it's the lowest since world war ii
not only that but at the out years
uh the the after a sugar high with all
of this money going to the economy
his expectations for growth are flat
under 2
so it's what's the point of spending all
of this money if it's not leading to
growth
but the real question i want to ask you
congressman is how is he planning on
paying for this
will he be able to raise taxes is he
going to get it through reconciliation
and whose taxes are going where tell us
the most egregious tax increases that
you see
you know maria what i think is the most
alarming within this budget proposal
you hit on the gdp in the president's
budget proposal he says gdp
over the first two years will be at 2.2
percent in the last
eight years of the budget it will be 1.9
the reason why it will be at 1.9 percent
is because his policies will be taking
effect
and his policies within this budget is
increasing taxes to the highest level
this country has ever seen
55 trillion dollars in collections of
taxes over the next 10 years
you're seeing increases on low income
working class president biden campaigned
and said that he would not raise taxes
on low income but in fact that's what he
does in this budget proposal
a family of four who makes less than
sixty thousand dollars a year
will face a two thousand dollar a year
increase
in taxes and i'll tell you a family of
four is doing everything they can to get
by right now
and with this crazy spending maria what
with inflation going around they're
already seeing a huge
increase of putting food on their table
clothes on their backs
medicine in their cabinets gas in their
cars it's absolutely getting out of
control
yeah congressman uh you really laid this
out well we so appreciate you walking us
through the budget
thank you sir we'll keep watching
congress jason smith
joining us